hey what's going on it's bill burns time
for the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast and I'm
just checking in on you see you know you
weeks go in huh making sure the Celtics
fans I [ __ ] you just got your ass
whipped by the Milwaukee Bucks the
Boston Slam is over and there's a lot of
people that are happy about that a lot
of sports fans are happy about that and
I'll ask you this what does that say
about you as a person that that's where
you get your joy in the failures of
others
you know Boston could have used a Sports
pick me up we only won the World Series
in the Superbowl this past year I'm just
[ __ ] with you I do the same thing
like I'm actually really upset that well
I guess it doesn't matter because the
Lakers aren't in it but I want Kevin
Durant to be totally healthy and if the
Celtics aren't going to win it just
anybody but the Lakers and but I think
that my hatred of the Lakers is
justified considering for whatever
reason they get to count a non NBA title
as an NBA title and I give it up to the
Lakers they are the most successful team
in my lifetime
sorry ampionship because my laptop's
full here empty in my trash they are
they're the most successful team the
[ __ ] amazing and they were able to
transition from the old school way right
into the free agency way better than the
Celtics have so I'll give them up on
that my only thing with them is take
that [ __ ] banner down you know quit
hitting off the ladies tees when all
your championships in the NBA I think
that that's fair but having said that I
didn't see a second of the Milwaukee
Bucks series but I definitely I don't
know though I definitely kind of saw I
didn't see us winning it this year I was
a little excited when we when we swept
the Pacers
but we just couldn't get into a groove
this year it just couldn't I don't know
what the [ __ ] happened it's almost like
I don't know it was like it was like
when you know and then music when they
put together a super band as they call
it it's like we'll get the bass player
from this huge band and we'll get the
drummer from this band and ba ba and all
that type of [ __ ] you think that this
thing's gonna sometimes it just doesn't
work and I think if you're a good Celtic
fan get off the [ __ ] Internet stop
[ __ ] pointing fingers that you clean
up your own [ __ ] life all right until
you put your hatred of the Lakers to bed
like me no you you're not gonna be doing
the Celtics any favor by going on there
and pointing the fingers and point your
finger at people and saying a bunch of
negative [ __ ] you know leave that to the
to the analysts or whatever they're
gonna say enough but you don't need to
fan the flames because what I'm worried
right now is what's going to happen is
everybody's gonna trash Kyrie Irving
blame him and then he's going to go sign
with somebody else and he's going to
have this fire in his belly and it's got
to come back to Hannes so just you know
whatever sometimes you ever see if
somebody redo a car and they just put
too much [ __ ] on it you know too many
bells and whistles the rims don't you
know should have picked a different rama
you didn't need this he didn't yeah it's
kind of like that was just a little bit
too much too much mustard on the hotdog
and I don't I just don't think there was
room enough for the amount of creativity
on that team that just wasn't enough
touches for everybody and people started
getting I don't know something happened
I don't know what they just couldn't get
into the flow but I do know that we have
the best [ __ ] young coach in the NBA
and we also have arguably one of the
best GM's and Danny Ainge so I believe
what we're gonna be able to fix this
thing but uh thank you to the Celtics
for uh enough you know we came up short
but it was still a great year and
congratulations to your Milwaukee Bucks
and I'd be lying to you as an NBA fan to
not say that it isn't exciting to see
that team
after all these years I mean that I
can't remember the last time they had a
nice run I imagine something happened
between Sidney Moncrief and Yanis I
mostly too to pool whatever I can't say
it's an take to compo sense him but that
is an exciting team to watch whatever
it's just it's good it's good what tink
you know it's not good one just [ __ ]
New York Boston and LA a [ __ ] doing
something and every goddamn year it's
it's just not good it's not good for the
[ __ ] league so I root for everybody
else and I am almost to the point now
where I'm letting go of my anger of like
like I just don't I don't I'm too old
now I just I don't give a [ __ ] all right
I'm not gonna sit here and waste time
and root against the [ __ ] Lakers even
though it's just trashing them the
Canadians and the Yankees like I don't
give a [ __ ] anymore because no matter
how much I hate them it's not gonna
change the result when they play the
game so what the [ __ ] am i doing all
right god bless all of them I root for
the Boston ones and if you beat us
congratulations how about that was that
for enlightened it is a big question
bill can you sustain it it's like I'm on
an emotional diet right now which I need
to go on a real [ __ ] diet after this
[ __ ] I had one [ __ ] Snickers bar in
an airport because they were boarding
and I didn't have time and I remember
that advertisement where they tried to
act like it was actually a decent
replacement for a meal
remember when Snickers had the balls to
do that it's a packed with peanuts
yes surrounded by [ __ ] the food
version of heroin sugar and I got back
on the sugar man I tied off I snorted
the first one and then I shot there I
ate more goddamn candy and dessert on
the last four days of this [ __ ] this
trip and I came home looking like I was
[ __ ] getting ready to play Santa
Claus on [ __ ] the next Christmas
holiday so I got back on it yesterday
it's just it's just hard to eat well
when you're on the
Road but people keep the vegetarian
meals coming in then I'm gonna I'm gonna
do like a hybrid my version sort of like
it like the way a rich kid goes to the
army you know to me I'm gonna be a
vegetarian the way George W Bush served
his country I'm gonna be in the
vegetarian reserves and you know not
show up for a few days
now why pick on him I don't know because
more [ __ ] bankrupt after that [ __ ]
2mg heart intelligence yeah it's [ __ ]
damn good
I was where's that guy could he come out
and say he's so like another word 20
trillion in debt ace sorry about
bankrupting your [ __ ] entire futures
I don't know
Bartnik kinda was talking to me about
some [ __ ] like that he was kind of
putting the last tube this one and a lot
the one before in perspective with what
they [ __ ] inherited it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] show it's like a water main break
broken they get you walked in there with
a [ __ ] wrench and a pair of rubber
boots and you're supposed to try and fix
it I don't know what I don't know but
that's too [ __ ] dark okay and I'm
taking it on the upswing here because
I'll tell you this I at this point I've
been to almost but I think I've been to
29 different countries 28 really I went
to the holy city to the Holy See which
is considered its own [ __ ] country
and the overwhelming thing that I have
found is people are nice people yeah
they're just decent the walk around
they're just [ __ ] nice and all of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] that's going on is the
concert the top because they want to
control everything and I already tell
you do just don't [ __ ] watch the news
I literally went to [ __ ] Israel not
watching the news had no idea that Hamas
had shot like [ __ ] six seven hundred
[ __ ] Rockets I don't fit into
Jerusalem or what had no idea just land
there I mean people immediately gave me
that information but you know people
[ __ ] nice they're [ __ ] nice and
when I got outside my hotel I saw some
Palestinian people and they were
peacefully protesting and it's just
people a [ __ ] that they're just nice
they're nice although this [ __ ] these
are evildoers and these [ __ ] people
and all these [ __ ] people but it's
not no no what it is is this [ __ ] like
you on the other side of the [ __ ]
fence smartest thing I ever did was I
stopped watching the news I really did
if you you know and I swear to God if I
wasn't in this [ __ ] business I'd get
off social media if you got off so
thinking if you did this if you got off
social media you stop watching the news
all right
and then you [ __ ] I don't know start
reading you know watch you know I
watched a really cool documentary watch
this one that there's this documentary
this kid made he was trying to do a
documentary with Bill Murray Bill Murray
never got to him then he kind of
realized other things what everybody was
kind of investigating all of these
stories about Bill Murray walking down
the street and then just jumping in a
kickball game with random people taking
pictures and disappearing just kind of
watch that thing the way that guy or at
least the way they're presenting the way
that dude lives his life it's pretty I
don't know maybe I was just stuck on an
airplane but it kind of affected me when
I was watching it I actually watched a
bunch of great movies on the twelve hour
flight before the four-hour delay the
connecting flight never connect when
you're traveling units or an
international you basically considering
its playoff times let's get to the
Exynos you basically just increased your
chances of a delayed flight by 100% as
you doubled the amount of planes that
you were taking a goddamn it had
happened I do want to give a shout-out
to United Airlines for making it happen
I thought you know these guys were up
against it with the by the time the
delay was over everybody the
stewardesses they would have flight
attendants everybody was up against it
and they still went anyways we were
supposed to get in at like 10:15 la time
we finally got it in like 3:00 a.m. and
I basically spent 24 hours
on planes and in an airport and it's
just one of those things where it's sofa
12-hour flight is so [ __ ] long you
don't even give a [ __ ] I just sit there
as a zygarde I stayed up for the entire
thing too and I the first thing I watch
was this Bill Murray documentary then I
watched make sure I get the names of
these movies right I watched that Jonah
Hill movie is it mid-90s said what it's
called mid-90s look that full movie pay
for that thing it cheap [ __ ] mid-90s
yeah Jonah Hill movie [ __ ] love that
movie great movie incredible
performances I love the writing and all
of that and I was like man this much got
great reviews whatever and I looked it
up and so much of the [ __ ] was about the
language the harsh language that was
used and all of that [ __ ] I just don't
know I don't understand when they
decided to treat every movie goer out
there like they're a [ __ ] child
you know what I mean I want remember
watching roots when I was a kid they
didn't have this big [ __ ] thing now
there's gonna be a lot of harsh things
that you're gonna see here you know
fruits came out now I think they would
literally be like you know is is that is
that the right thing to put out now is
this gonna start slavery again it's just
like this is the way people talked that
the title of the movie is literally
called mid-90s if that 1890s I don't
understand just watch the movie it was
[ __ ] like I was really blown away by
the performances too and I also loved
the ending which is the hardest thing to
land is the third act without doing some
sort of thing that people can see they
can see the end coming or something like
that it was just a [ __ ] phenomenal
movie so congratulations to Jonah Hill
and everybody else that was in it the
acting the actors in it was just they
were just there I was so [ __ ] great
man I'd really love that movie all right
and then
next up I saw I watched on the
waterfront and finally [ __ ] paid
attention cuz I had to credible movie I
know that's like one of the best ones of
all time but I actually sat and watched
it loved that one then I watched I gotta
make sure I get this one right to the
Laurel & Hardy movie another great one I
was just standing Ollie I watched that
movie and just once again absolutely
fantastic [ __ ] movie I made sure I
picked good woods yet onto me as if I'm
gonna City I'm gonna make sure I watched
you know I remember Marc Maron was
raving about that movie so I'm gonna I
was like I'm gonna watch this but uh
Steve Coogan and john c reilly Shirley
Henderson and Nina Arianda they were
like the main they play basically Laurel
and Hardy and then their significant
others and Nina Arianda her character
was [ __ ] hilarious definitely checked
that one out then was that that's one
two three said three or four fourth
that's four with the Bill Murray thing
and then I watched I start I was like
alright man like these are really great
movies but you really have to pay
attention let me watch something a
little sillier and they had st. Elmo's
fire was on there and I got through
maybe eight minutes of that movie it was
oh man it was dude when when when
[ __ ] what now two [ __ ] his name when
he takes Rob Lowe's head and he stuffs
it in a [ __ ] toilet in a bar and he
the guy doesn't get mad he's like uh you
know whatever the wet look is in I'm
like okay alright and then for the third
time they did that they all told a joke
and they all went but I'll bump and then
they had that little [ __ ] thing that
they we get it they have camaraderie
their college friends I was just like
all right
Plus basically everybody had this look
on their face that they were just really
enjoying being famous
I think that was a good time for any of
those actors because I'd like all the
actors in that movie but that was just
like they had that look on their face
like yeah this is never going to end
not all of them anyway so I shut that
one off and I was like all right I'm not
I'm not you know this is actually gonna
make the flight seem longer so then in
the last movie I watched what the hell
did I watch I just went blank I watched
another really good one this is how my
brains work because I literally knew the
movie and then I thought wait what was
the one previous to it and then if I go
previous it just erases the last thought
oh I remember I watched what happened to
Baby Jane
starring Betty Davis and I don't want to
say that Joan Collins the other Joan let
me say Betty Davis and Joan Crawford and
I always heard that you know they did a
whole movie about how they didn't
[ __ ] like each other and all of this
type of [ __ ] I watched that movie that's
one of those movie that's it's like the
performances and everything are really
good then it keeps going out off the
road and then it comes back there is
sort of a major hole in it where you
know some [ __ ] that's happened before
you get to see them it's like and the
cops didn't intervene and then they were
cool with the two of them just hanging
out as it does that what happened all
the studio fixed it I actually really
enjoyed it and there's an actor in it
who I really [ __ ] loved and it turned
out I'm gonna get his name here it
turned out that he actually was the one
that played King Tut on the Batman
series was a phenomenal actor I was like
who the [ __ ] is that guy what's his name
Wow for [ __ ] sakes
I said Victor Buono said oh you say his
name yes
larger than life ran with the
eloquent king-sized appetite from
maniacal merriment who the [ __ ] wrote
this [ __ ] Jesus Christ he didn't live
long ago died of 43 there must have been
the old heart-attack people trying to
get the weight off trying to keep the
forget the weight up and try and keep it
off don't eat a bunch of [ __ ] candy
like I did so anyways I recommend all of
those movies and I guess st. Elmo's fire
too if you're doing some research on the
brat pack if I was gonna watch the brat
pack movie I would watch The Breakfast
Club I think that that was the
high-water mark of that but uh st.
Elmo's fire wasn't a good one oh the
other ones about last night what was the
one that had Andrew McCarthy and Rob
Lowe and they both went to college and I
think I know I can't I can't talk about
the we without giving the [ __ ] thing
away but it has one of the most
anticlimactic endings to a movie I've
ever seen I'm not ripping either actor
cuz I think they did a good job but it's
just like did they just improv the end
of that [ __ ] thing I don't want to
ruin that one any all right what am i
[ __ ] Siskel and Ebert here shut the
[ __ ] up bill whatever that's why that's
what I watched then I got home finally
got home and about you know 3:30 4:00 in
the morning and I was able to yesterday
sleep a little bit right now it's 4:00
in the morning my time I was able to
stay up till about 4:00 in the afternoon
yesterday gonna watch the Celtics game I
was like I'm gonna close my eyes for an
hour and I woke up at 8:00 and I was
like [ __ ] because a pipe burst in my
house shout out to my wife handling that
whole [ __ ] thing one of the main
things you can greatest things you can
ever teach your wife is how to shut off
the [ __ ] water in your house before
major what damage gets done and she
handled that like a champ by the time
she woke me up the plumbers were already
there and they fixed it so I don't know
as I've said this house has a lot of
character it's got a lot of character
everybody a lot of [ __ ] character
run and hide if anybody ever says out of
a house that you're thinking about buy
all right but the Boston Bruins and your
North Carolina Hurricanes
are getting ready to show first game
tonight 5:00 p.m. West Coast time 8:00
p.m. East Coast time [ __ ] 7:00 p.m.
Central time and 6:00 p.m. mountain time
did I handle everything what time is it
in Hawaii I don't know probably starts
it like [ __ ] 1:00 in the afternoon
2:00 in the afternoon I don't know
Honolulu time 4 o'clock Alaska time the
Bruins start their series with the very
difficult Carolina Hurricanes have no
idea I don't know anything about this
team other than that they've been an
absolute buzzsaw since the beginning of
April so this should be another tough
one I don't know why they give it
Marshawn [ __ ] for that little [ __ ]
snarky [ __ ] reporter giving him a
rough time somebody tried to equate it
to how I missed the whole series Charlie
McAvoy I guess had a hit that was up
high possibly dirty you know hit against
somebody on the Columbus Blue Jackets
he's like and they're still able to
shake hands
why doesn't Brad Marchand give more than
one word answers to this [ __ ]
jerk-off reporter because he's not on
the ice that's why he's not a player
stop baby this guy right this whole
[ __ ] article like the reporters are
just like people wouldn't even know what
was going on we totally would know what
was going on we're not there for your
report we're there for the game we're
watching the [ __ ] game people would
still watch literally if there was no
[ __ ] announcers it wouldn't be as
good would not be as good alright but I
would say right now that the level of
coverage it's it's it's so above and
beyond anything that's even needed where
did that where did that [ __ ] thing
even happen it happened during the
warm-ups before a [ __ ] playoff game
and Marshawn took time out of warming up
for a crucial [ __ ] playoff game to
talk to this [ __ ] [ __ ] and then he
starts giving him [ __ ] like he's
actually picked sides
and he skated away like he should have I
liked what he did and I liked that he
gave one-word answers but of course the
press is always gonna have the last
answer and then they're gonna bring up
you know you lick a few faces a couple
of soso foot so the next thing you know
you can never get a break in the press
but that's just how it is that's just
how it is but all I know is is that Brad
Marchand the Boston Bruins have moved on
to the Eastern Conference Finals and
that [ __ ] reporter has not someone's
gonna hoist the trophy this year the
Stanley Cup and they're gonna skate
around with him I can tell you one
person who isn't that [ __ ] guy and me
so why don't you shut the [ __ ] up with
you a little snarky he didn't if he just
asked him about the play then he goes
hey did you get your skates sharp and he
sounded like a [ __ ] blue jacket fan
so [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] his Instagram and
all that [ __ ] not saying to go on and
trash him cuz that's that's even worse
that's even worse than what I'm doing
here on the podcast so being jet lag I
was able to get caught up with some of
the MotoGP although I haven't a problem
with their [ __ ] their website I guess
they haven't uploaded the the replay of
the the race from Spain yet but I was
able to watch the one from Austin Texas
where Marc Marquez was in turn 12 which
I guess is a difficult turn because you
come down from that straightaway and he
got a slow go from 6 gear all the way
down to first gear and I don't know what
happened they kept saying trail braking
I'm not a motorcycle guy I tried to be
that guy for [ __ ] two months out here
in LA and all I could kept thinking
about was the time Richie Cunningham got
the motorcycle and Fonzie was telling
not to get it and then he ended up
having a [ __ ] accident cuz you know
what he was a car guy one of the most
dangerous things out there if you're
riding a motorcycle beyond people
texting alright is is while they're
driving is to have a car guy on a
motorcycle and I I was able to recognize
that myself so anyways there was nobody
near him and he just [ __ ] wiped out
he just wiped out and then couldn't get
the bike started and then and he got no
championship points so was huge
obviously for him to get a win here any
I think he's right I think he's back up
by one
because davut she also had a oh no I'm
confusing races Vichy also had a great
start in the the Austin won and they did
a little bit a blue blue and the [ __ ]
first turn and then that was it for him
the whole [ __ ] day I still don't
understand why how I I do like it I
think what makes motorcycle racing
interesting to me is they just how
certain bikes are just why are certain
bikes better in the corners and other
bikes are better on the straightaway is
it simply the way that they have them
set up or does it literally hey we'll
just make it a better [ __ ] engine for
this thing is it how I always hear like
how I've missed the glory days of
Formula One because now the cars are too
evenly matched and it's all about racing
to the first turn and whoever's gets to
the first turn and then the ones who win
the [ __ ] thing that seems to be what
happens in Formula One but I was not
able to watch the last f1 race which I'm
gonna watch here now at like 4:00 in the
morning when I finished this podcast and
I believe Lewis Hamilton is just I think
he won that one again I mean I don't
know this it's literally just like which
Mercedes driver is gonna win it this
year or more accurately does valtteri
botas have a run in him to stop the
inevitable so I'm gonna go upstairs I'm
gonna [ __ ] watch that when I get done
recording this thing had to go
downstairs into the LA version of a
basement and record this thing because I
don't want to wake up my lovely daughter
who I had not seen in [ __ ] eight days
crushed me right and I came home and she
woke up early or whatever and I was
psyched because I was up and I went in
there to get her up and I was waiting to
see her beautiful face light up that oh
my god I'm seeing I'm seeing daddy right
and I came in and she a big smile on her
face and the first thing she said to me
was I want mama so I just left you know
got her up changed her and all that type
of stuff and then it's unreal
I hate me in a way like that but I did I
did bring everybody to Iceland and we
had aa amazing week there so I mean and
you know what this is how I keep the
lights on so I do have to you
go out and go to work plumber has to go
go out and fix the [ __ ] sinks and I
have to go out and go tell my jokes I
will tell you though just being away a
week she got even taller and now she can
like put her pajama top on herself
all by herself she can move her arm
around and get through the sleeve and
it's just like Jesus Christ go away for
a week they grow by leaps and bounds so
anyway I got her out of bed and you know
I was stiff as hell from being on the
plane so I so she goes let's go see mama
and I said alright well hang on a second
I got a stretch first what's hilarious
is when I do my stretches she does him
with me and that she imitates the noises
that I make so like I did like the
forward bend you know to start yoga you
know you grab your elbows or whatever do
a forward bend and I you know when I got
past basically certain levels I go uh
and then she does hers and she goes uh
she just Emmitt
she laughed she thinks I'm being funny
rather than just being old so she comes
into the bedroom now and she takes the
foam roller and she puts it down and she
sits down on it and how the her height
it's like a little chair and she sits
down on and she's gonna thinking that
like that's what you're supposed to do
whether the whether it hurts or not
she's the best and I'm home for a little
bit before I have an acting gig that
shoots this entire summer I don't know I
think they already they already put some
stuff out about it it's a I usually tell
jokes and [ __ ] about the [ __ ] that I
meant but I'm actually in a Pete
Davidson movie vehicle that that with
Judd Apatow and all those guys so I'm
very excited to be in this thing and I
got to eat perfectly here for the next
few weeks it'd be in the the right kind
of shape you know what's great though is
when you are my age is acceptable to
acceptable to be in a certain level of
shape you know he's 50 I'm gonna turn 51
on this [ __ ] shoot anyways by the way
it's Mother's Day it is Mother's Day
everybody coming up this Sunday don't
forget let me read a little bit of
advertising here and then that'll be it
here all right dolly shave
dude Dollar Shave Club is everything you
need to look feel and smell your best
and you never have to go to the store
oh after what after I'm done reading
these things I'm gonna tell you about my
show in Israel and Tel Aviv specifically
that's because they deliver everything
you need right to your door and they
keep you fully stocked on what you use
so you don't run out here's how it works
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready no matter what you're
getting ready for they have you covered
head to toe for your hair your skin your
face you name it they have it and they
have this new program where they
automatically keep you stocked up on the
products you use you determine what you
want when you want it and it shows up
right at your door from once a month to
once every six months plus with their
handsome discount the more you buy the
more you save and right now Dollar Shave
Club has a bunch of starter sets you can
get for just $5 like their oral care kit
after that the restock box ships regular
size products at regular price get you
start a set for just five dollars right
now with Darla's Shave Club com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / / alright
LegalZoom running a small business is a
lot of work it takes time and money and
you want all the time and money you have
to go towards growing your business but
what happens when legal hurdles pop up
along the way Legal Zoom is there to
help nearly 2 million Americans have
used Legal Zoom to start their
businesses with LLC's and corporations
and more but even after your business is
set up Legal Zoom can still help out
things like lease agreements changing
tax laws and contract reviews are all
part of running your own business and
these are precisely the kinds of costly
hurdles that can take time away from
growing your business that's why Legal
Zoom created their business legal plan
get advice for running your business
from vetted independent attorneys and
tax professionals available in all 50
states the best part is you don't you
won't get charged by the hour since
Legal Zoom isn't a law firm make your
time make your time and money work for
you check out Legal Zoom Business Legal
Zoom but check out Legal Zoom business
legal plan at legalzoom.com a lot of
legal in there now and get special
savings when you enter birth check out
Legal Zoom where life me
legal legalzoom.com and one more for you
old zip hiring used to be hard
hiring used to be had multiple job sites
stacks of resumes a confusing review
process but today hiring can be easy and
you only have to go to one place to get
it done that's all zip comm / / zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and spots
lights the top candidates so you never
miss a great match zip bag is so
effective that four out of five
employees who post on SAP get a quality
candidate through the site within the
first day and right now my listeners can
try zip recruiting for free for an
exclusive web address zip recruiter comp
/ / that zip recruited comm / / spell it
out zi peek our ECR u ITER comm / /
that's it
[Music]
the smartest way to hire alright um I
did a show in Tel Aviv I actually
recorded that show hopefully I didn't
take the audio straight from the board I
don't know if it's been miked up but I
just wanted to hit I just had a feeling
I was gonna have it was just gonna be
one of those sometimes you just you just
you just feel it you know not saying
that the others ones weren't I think the
last time I talked to you I just done
Helsinki which was amazing Oslo was
crazy [ __ ] crazy show I had close to
six or seven thousand people show up and
then we went to we went to us punk ass
is gonna go a little long then we went
to Amsterdam and that was like 3,500
people could believe like that many
[ __ ] people showed up other side of
the world just to hear my [ __ ] [ __ ]
and dick jokes was amazing and we went
out in Oslo went out and I smoked a
cigar my frigging cigar smoking is off
the rails I really got to reel that in
you know I feel like in a way that I
kind of replaced the fact that I wasn't
drinking which was hard when I was going
through Europe so all of a sudden I'm
[ __ ] eating candy bars and smoking
cigarettes [ __ ] craziness just
because I'm addicted to some sort of
buzz at the end of the day so once I
have to [ __ ] get back to what I was
doing which was putting on my PJs and
when [ __ ] reading a book which I
would have done because I was I have
like 25 more pages ago in that Beastie
Boy book but it was the hardcover
special edition so I was like sticking a
[ __ ] extra laptop in my bag and I
didn't want to check a bag so I didn't
bring it so I should have brought like
this paperback book somebody got me on
The Simpsons or something like that and
done that instead but I didn't so now I
have to live with my decisions so anywho
I let me see what was that oh yeah so
Oslo we ended up going out when we were
in Oslo Oslo is that how you say it and
they took us out to this this bar it was
funny was freezing cold out we walked
home and they were going yeah I just let
you know you know because they want to
go you want to take a cab it's just like
a six five six minute walk but like I
let's walk
we get out of those freezing out and the
guy goes yeah just let you know this is
the bad part of town like a lot of
people don't like coming down to this
part of town it's like well you know you
probably should have said that you know
five minutes ago and we were deciding
how we were gonna get home something
about walking and it was just like I
don't know I mean it was definitely some
drunk people there didn't seem too
[ __ ] crazy granted I was only in that
part of town for five minutes and who
really mugged somebody in a freezing
cold night you know I always feel like
people that mug people like yeah I'm
gonna [ __ ] stay in tonight you know
put on my PJs and read a book I'm not a
mug people better you know mugging for
dummies whatever the [ __ ] they would
read then I went to went to Amsterdam
the next day ate at this amazing [ __ ]
egg place that was right down the street
they had a gourmet chicken sandwich one
of those places I ordered and then like
I'm sorry we sold we were sold out of
that sandwich you're like oh this is one
of these places right it was delicious
if you're gonna Amsterdam send me an
email and I'll let you know what the
[ __ ] it is because I don't have the
information with me right now I'm sure
you can just find it on [ __ ] if you
just google it God knows that's how I
found it and then I went to we went out
to I forget the name of the place there
was just some bar where you could just
go in he'd just order weed and smoke
some weed and so if they had milkshakes
too so I said I'd [ __ ] it so me bartnick
waited in there and I am NOT a big weed
guy and I'm still not and I don't know
this was this body high so I smoked it
now it's just like I'm not high
I don't feel high right now and I think
it was cuz it was a body high cuz the
next day I woke up and I definitely feel
like you know something happened so I
don't know I don't know if I I guess I
was I don't know all I know is I enjoyed
the [ __ ] out of that [ __ ] milkshake
and it also took me like I asked for a
vanilla milkshake and then the woman
showed up and she goes when she brought
the orders like did you ask for vanilla
or strawberry I can't remember it's like
yeah because everybody's smoking weed in
here and I was and I looked at it and it
looked like a vanilla shake cuz it was
all white said I accept I go yeah no
that sets
that's vanilla and it wasn't till I was
like 3/4 of the way through then I kind
of got to the clump of the ice of it
that the clump of the milkshake you know
it's all stuck together that's I guess
we're all the strawberries we're I don't
know I don't know but that was sort of
interesting I got to be honest with you
though dude I just I'm not into it just
not into weed I'm just like I don't know
I just I don't like sitting around like
hey man like I'm just a [ __ ] chillin
here me life's not [ __ ] not I would
rather smoke a cigar and then just sit
there which is an obnoxious thing to do
I will tell you though if if you are a
single person you know and you got a
little bit of [ __ ] time off I mean
that part of the world is a great place
to go Norway if in Finland that women
which is [ __ ] gorgeous ridiculous
they just have like regular jobs cuz
there's so many of them you know you
leave the order room service you're
looking at this woman it's like you
would be reading the national news in my
country well that's say they're all like
that but Jesus Christ man that's it was
you know I don't feel like a troll when
I'm walking around over there
so then lastly but leastly we did our
show in tel-aviv and man I just had this
feeling I was like I just got a feeling
that shows gonna be one of those shows
and it was it was like I feel like the
last three shows Norway Amsterdam and
then something happened when I was in
when I was in Helsinki where I was just
like all right just whatever just do
what you always do whatever joke you
think and just do that one next because
I was really doing this rigorous like I
must dump my last hour of material and I
must do all of these new bits that I
have and the new bits are working or I
wouldn't I wouldn't be doing them
because people paid money to see me but
there was no flow to him it was kind of
like the Celtics this year all these
[ __ ] ideas but it was just like you
know the transitions were a little
awkward and sad [ __ ] this I'm just gonna
just do my [ __ ] and it just kind of came
to a peak when I went to Tel Aviv and it
just could not have been a better
[ __ ] crowd and I you know found out
when I was over there
that like ten percent of their
population doesn't even [ __ ] pay
taxes and up from what I can understand
it was the the Jewish people who dress
up like like the sort of the the pilgrim
look without the buckle on the front and
the curlicue hair on the side I don't
know if it's every one of them but it
was just like dude what the [ __ ] how to
[ __ ] especially in Israel you can't kick
in for a little bit of something to
defend your people it dad that's just
you know I don't get that at all cuz God
knows there's people in my country doing
the same [ __ ] thing making billions
and billions and millions of [ __ ]
dollars and they don't pay any [ __ ]
taxes and then nobody goes after them
and then when the bill comes in oh it's
a little higher they all we got a tax
the people that are already the honest
people already pay in taxes we got to
tax them more and what kills me is
people who make less money are like yeah
that's the solution nobody goes oh we
got to go after these [ __ ]
freeloading so anyways I made fun of
that came right out opened with that so
I was just like I gotta see you know
where where these people are at I did a
Hitler joke that also killed now
society's [ __ ] people are cool and we
just I just had like the best [ __ ]
time and afterwards I met like I think
just about every comedian in Israel we
did a group photo we were having a great
time and this woman kept saying all
right all right get out leave me alone
leave me alone I said they're not
bothering me and then she goes yes they
are it's like oh I'm sorry I didn't
realize you're more in touch with I
should have put my foot down over
something like lady lady that they're
not they're not relax relax
okay they're not bother I'm not just
being nice I like meeting comedians so
anyway I met them and then when I walked
outside there was all these people
hanging out and you know I took all
these pictures I met some guy from
Turkey came down from Turkey just to see
my act which was so flattering it was
another woman there was like I don't
know like it looked like you know seven
eight months
pregnant you know took time to come out
to the show it's just one of those
nights and afterwards me Bartnik and
club soda Kenny like we didn't we didn't
want the night to end so we'd already
smoked like two of the best cigars I've
ever had it was this right next to my
hotel that was like this little like
bodega that sold everything from [ __ ]
M&Ms and ice cream in beer and wine to
[ __ ] and they had Cuban cigars and I
don't know what that little humidor
system was but they smell the draw on
them was incredible so the first day we
smoked day I came up we talked about
this because I know I recorded the
afternoon of the show the first one we
smoked was a it was a Cohiba robustos
and then the next day it was I don't
have to say part Potter gets apart agus
we smoked the the series D which is
their version I think of a reboost oh
and there was two of the best [ __ ]
cigars and we just was sitting there
right on a Jaffa Beach sitting on a park
bench watching people go by and you know
there was a church what are they really
call it they don't call it is it a
synagogue a temple some dude would just
I don't know on the hour or whatever
would start singing and [ __ ] say
Hebrew you just be sitting there right
like you weren't getting enough for the
[ __ ] vibe of Israel all of a sudden
this guy would just mad at me party we
just look at each other and smile like
they were in [ __ ] Israel we just sat
there looking at the beautiful
Mediterranean Sea smoking this cigar so
that later on that night were like what
do you want to do is I feel you wanna
smoke another cigar it's like dude I
can't I can't I've already broke my rule
not smoking a cigar before a show and I
did that [ __ ] throat is on fire here
so I went to that bodega and I just got
a little finger ice-cream [ __ ]
hilarious
three big meatheads walking down the
beach eating ice cream you know it like
[ __ ] ten
at night and just set they just went
over the whole tour in our heads just
talking about you know just how much fun
we had and what a [ __ ] experience it
was we went all the way back to like do
remember when we were Reykjavik Iceland
meeting all those comedians and going up
there and that that one Icelandic
comedian with the crazy laugh he had us
laugh like how the [ __ ] goes I can't
remember was just like he's crazy
[ __ ] laugh and he went onstage and he
was funny as hell and listening to them
talking about the secret cellar and
their whole comedy thing and and then we
were off Copenhagen Stockholm Finland
and then the rest of the ones I just
talked about it couldn't it just was
just really one of those [ __ ] tours
and I got to be honest with you I'm
starting to think like I liked traveling
internationally to do stand-up like I
don't have to deal with like I do
stand-up now in the States and it's just
like what do you get offstage like what
the [ __ ] that I say and it what's gonna
be taken seriously that I'd go too far
on that one is that gonna be some sort
of [ __ ] issue and I don't know it's
probably why I went so over-the-top on
my latest special coming out and also
why I love the new Nick DiPaolo special
that's out you know and I don't agree
with everything that the guy says but
just the fact that someone can get out
there and just [ __ ] say what they're
thinking anyways and I know there's
gonna be a bunch of people on the left
you're gonna be like me and you again
it's like you tell me the difference
between that [ __ ] special that far to
the right and some of these other
specials that far to the left you know
that you get to the point where this
just people just on stage saying liberal
agenda there's there's no laughing
people to just applause break the
younger comics funny as hell they told
me they call it those comics they go in
stage and they get clapped her nobody's
[ __ ] laughing so this is the answer
to that and it's like if you don't want
somebody going that hard and the other
side then you you know it's gotten
[ __ ] crazy
like people need to sort of meet in the
middle and and listen to each other and
respect the fact that we're all [ __ ]
living here and that people have
different views on things rather than
just being like which I'll never my life
that I ever think that I would see the
left get to the [ __ ] point where it's
just like say what we say think what we
think and if you don't we're going to
destroy your [ __ ] career I was
actually reading you know because I you
know just watching those old movies and
watching Joan Crawford and Betty Davis
you know then all these you start
looking them up and then they'll still
show like Lauren Bacall and all these
great Ingrid Bergman and all these great
actresses from back in the day and I
think it was Lauren Bacall had a thing
saying how she was liberal
saying being a liberal is the greatest
thing this isn't like the 1940s or 50s
being a liberal is the greatest thing
that you can be it makes you open-minded
and accepting of others and just and I
was I was just shaking my head going
yeah that's what it used to be I don't I
don't think it was always that because I
always do think that I don't think that
I don't know back when I was growing up
I mean politicians have always been
filthy but like they had like that that
they kind of enjoyed the back-and-forth
it wasn't as nasty as it is now but but
whatever you just listen to a guy who
doesn't even [ __ ] watch the news and
miss most of the sporting events but
tonight I got a little bit of rehearsal
for that film I'm gonna start the game a
little bit late but go Bruins as always
and I'm looking forward to another great
series congratulations to the Columbus
Blue Jackets on a phenomenal season
congratulations to the Milwaukee Bucks
moving on I'm gonna enjoy watching you
guys I think I'm gonna uh maybe I'll
root for the Bucs I don't know I saw
Durant thank God Durant didn't blow out
his Achilles that's like the [ __ ]
worst for a basketball or any athletes
so it's just a calf strain so should
maybe watch the rest of that series God
knows I got nothing to do and I'm really
tempted to fill up all my free time with
going out and flying a [ __ ]
helicopter but uh I've learned that that
adds stress and drains me when I fill up
all everything in my life and then I
[ __ ] start getting upset and then
people suffer so I got to stop [ __ ]
doing that [ __ ] so I think I'll only fly
like twice instead of four times I
I am wired the way I'm worried I'm doing
the goddamn Comedy Jam on Monday the
last show at the Jesus Christ what's the
name of the [ __ ] venue at the Roxy
Monday May 13th at 9 p.m. and I got to
get this song together I'm playing a
song that's just wait
yeah May 13th yeah I'm playing I'm
playing a song as always I'm always
reaching beyond unless I play like
highway to hell I mean even then you
know that song is not as easy as you'd
think as far as just playing something
that simple making it sound good so I am
reaching beyond my ability so let's see
I'm waiting for this thing to [ __ ]
load here all I can see is the other two
names they sit says Jeff Ross and Maas
so that's obviously Jobrani Maz Jobrani
Jeff Ross myself Josh Adam Myers his
wonderful band and this will be the last
one at the Roxy Theatre I think they've
actually maybe outgrown it and they're
gonna move on to a bigger venue so I'm
gonna be down there trying out my new
jokes forcing them down your throats and
then I'm gonna get up and make a fool of
myself playing drums as always it's
gonna be it's gonna be a great time I
hope - Rose is gonna be there I'm not
sure if he is why won't this [ __ ]
thing tell me who's on the lineup
oh there it is uh I think the name of
the [ __ ] promoters on there come on
who else is gonna be on this [ __ ]
thing look at me look at me it's so
early the morning can't actually do an
hour here on the Thursday podcast all it
has is the names of the promoters oh man
look at that cheeseburger
jeez the internet they just know they
[ __ ] know they date that's why they
want to have the cookies everywhere so
they are we see what he's into and then
we can and that [ __ ] Patriots jacket
I'm not gonna buy it I feel like if I
finally buy that thing when I click you
know the PayPal to pay for it
the my computer's gonna go ha ha ha ha
you know we knew you couldn't resist for
those of you who I haven't been
listening with podcasts I I went on
Mitchell & Ness I love that website even
though I look like a jerk-off and all of
their [ __ ] you know all of their
[ __ ] stuff just because I'm an old
guy here but I looked up I was this is
Patriots jacket that I wanted when I was
a little kid nice till I finally found
it and who made it but uh they
discontinued it was a cheap jacket
anyways the sleeves look leather but I
believe there was some sort of vinyl and
then it was supposed to be sort of a
wool you know it's like a varsity jacket
and the jacket part that fit around like
a bulletproof vest that part of the
jacket is was supposed to be wool but it
was this pillowy cheap [ __ ] and the
whole thing was a mess but I went on
Mitchell and Ness first to see if they
had done a version of the jacket and
they didn't and I looked at some
Patriots jackets and I swear to god this
was like [ __ ] two months ago 60 days
ago and they won't let up they won't let
up which means somebody at least 60 days
in that they just kept showing the ad to
finally clicked and said yeah I'm gonna
buy that [ __ ] thing how hilarious is
that Oh advertising all right that's it
thank you to everybody came out to my
shows I'm back here in the u.s. I'm
gonna watch the Bruins tonight and I
think Joe Rogan is out at the ice house
if I get a [ __ ] second wind we'll see
we'll see I might be too [ __ ] tired
I'm not officially on that [ __ ] show
but there's a chance I might I might
drop by I shouldn't say that because
most likely won't all right there's the
honest I most likely won't but right now
at [ __ ] 4:30 7 a.m. I'm feeling like
I could [ __ ] do that to take a little
catnap
alright that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
have a great weekend and I'll talk to
you on Monday
nobody told me no wanna never close
nobody want me nobody want me that you
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday May 9th 2011 how the hell are you
guys yeah that's [ __ ] great I'm here
at the K Rock Studios this week a very
special very special edition of the
Monday morning podcast because I'm doing
this huge comedy tour that Jim Norton
put together with stars Jimmy Norton
Dave Attell Jim Breuer and myself the
antisocial Network tour and we are
hyping the date May 13th we're gonna be
in Washington DC add our Constitution
Hall or some [ __ ] I don't know I don't
know why that's Omar laughing in the
background he's gonna he's gonna be
doing the actually working the bores
people have always complained about how
awful your levels are my levels are you
know what I like to do I like to take
the base and turn it all the way down
and then just crank up the high end nice
so it makes people's ears bleed
absolutely that's that's what I go is so
anyways we're gonna be hyping that this
week Jim Norton is actually gonna call
in Dave Attell is gonna call in Jim
Breuer was actually too busy so whatever
we got two out of three you know one of
the biggest tours out there as I've said
before the sort of a Miami Heat of
comedy tours or possibly the Ocean's
eleven if seven of them died tragically
and then four decided to carry on and do
a [ __ ] comedy show so anyways I will
waiting for Jim Norton to call in at
this moment so well I'm gonna do what I
always do I'm gonna riff Omar if I look
at you and I look panicked okay and I'm
feeling [ __ ] nuts
will riff a little bit okay but until
then just act like I'm not even here
let's just make this is [ __ ] weird as
humanly possibly uncomfortable I'm so
anyways let's see what is going to start
with this week why don't we start
talking about sports everybody huh the
[ __ ] Bruins finished off the goddamn
filthy Flyers which made me feel good
and for all flier fans out there I'm not
even going to talk [ __ ] I'm not even
gonna gloat because I was beyond nervous
when we were up three games to none
because of what happened to us last year
I was actually I was actually praying
not praying I was kind of hoping on some
level that you guys would win one of the
first three games so so even if we
the series it wouldn't again be from
[ __ ] being up three games to none so
I have to admit I don't know if you
noticed but when you guys tied up game
for it one one did you notice how quiet
the [ __ ] garden got so we were all
nervous about that [ __ ] but that's it
man enjoy your golfing go [ __ ]
yourselves
with your little [ __ ] creamsicle
uniforms it's over it's [ __ ] over for
you once again and hopefully we won't be
right behind you cuz I'm [ __ ] nervous
about playing Tampa Bay because they
have they got three [ __ ] on that team
that can put the biscuit in the basket
as they say and I'm really uh I don't
[ __ ] know it's the Bruins you don't I
mean every time you get excited and you
like you know that this might be the
year this could be it I was speaking of
filthy flyers what about that [ __ ]
at the end of the game was it because we
get we scored two empty net goals that
you decided to give patrice bergeron a
mild concussion the basic the Jason Kidd
of our [ __ ] team is that what you had
to do I'm really happy that
what's-his-face Josh Hart and all
actually shaved off all that [ __ ]
hair that he had I really hated that
home Mac Davis look that he was rocking
and I couldn't I got a mitt I didn't
even notice him in the in the series I
think he's like Thor like he cut off his
[ __ ] hey who's the guy you pick if
you cut off his [ __ ] hair Samson
he said Samson Samson are you one of
those comic book nerds who will no get
into all this [ __ ] no I you asked me
anything about comic books I don't have
any clue yeah [ __ ] movies Thor I mean
how much you scraping the bottom of the
barrel when you're down to the guy who
has a hammer he's got this [ __ ]
hammer and he and that's all his power
and then [ __ ] his dad throws it down
to the earth like III gotta admit I
understand that me being into sports at
the level I'm at and the fact that I
don't even play is roughly the same
thing I guess but at least sports is
real the [ __ ] is wrong with you guys
with your goddamn Thor wallpaper and
Flash pajamas and they've how many how
many [ __ ] good movies do they even
make with these superhero movies
honestly did you guys really like
spider-man were you really into that
where they they gave him a girlfriend
with those little teeth
remember that and he's [ __ ] kissing
her upside they turned it into a [ __ ]
love story so they could get you to
bring you [ __ ] broad down to the
movie theater spider-man did not have a
not good looking or a mediocre whoever
the [ __ ] played his wife in those movies
I would not be nervous approaching in a
bar and that there's something wrong
with that being a balding redhead okay
there's something wrong I I should be I
should be beyond nervous but I wasn't I
remember when I saw the [ __ ] movie I
remember thinking where's the
raven-haired big hip big titty
girlfriend that he had in the comic
books and she was nowhere to be found
Kirsten Dunst that's what it was with
their little toddler teeth sitting there
smiling at him she's awful she looked
like a picture you'd see in like one of
those one of those fairy tales the
fables you know be like the girlfriend
I'm being too mean to her I was gonna
say the [ __ ] girlfriend of the troll
under the bridge anyways this is
probably odd too they actually have them
hearing you laughing in the background
usually it's just me sort of like
babbling to my mind in the bedroom you
know what yeah bring that down just so
because you know people are in the
[ __ ] Internet no matter what they're
gonna trash it the podcast sucked what
the [ __ ] was that guy giggling in the
background for him I'm gonna have to
deal with all of that all of that horse
[ __ ] so like I said when I look at you
in a moment of panic like I don't know
where the [ __ ] this is gonna be going
for the love of God bring up your mic
and and save me but like I said we're
sitting here we're waiting for for the
legendary Jim Norton star I was actually
looking at his IMDB page and I didn't
realize all the [ __ ] that this guy's
done he just recently did a spot on
bored to death hit television show I
believe on HBO or Showtime he's a
best-selling author he's got two books
happy endings I hate your guts he's got
a brand new CD out called despicable
available look at me I'm hyping his [ __ ]
before he even gets on the goddamn phone
by the way when I gave him the phone
number to call in they are gonna it's
gonna light up here right the phone
numbers are gonna light up okay I'm just
making sure
all right this takes me back to the days
I used to do a show back with the teen
idol sensation from the Opie and Anthony
showed
judge Joe DeRosa I used to do a show we
used to try to take collars and used to
always be a [ __ ] nightmare so this is
actually taking me back you know we used
to actually do this show called
uninformed that we're trying desperately
to bring back the problem is is that we
live on opposite coasts I don't know if
we can tie in Skype we got to figure out
a [ __ ] way to do that but we used to
take collars and because it was a brand
new show we might as well been like I'm
like like public-access we just go like
hey we're talking about apple trees
anybody want to call in on that and then
we would just have [ __ ] callers call
in anyway what talking about apple trees
you can pick it up and what did you go
[ __ ] yourself you [ __ ] and then they'd
hang up on us so we stopped taking
callers and I learned my lesson so this
um this week I'm just gonna have fellow
artist fellow artist Colin but wait a
minute you know I'm getting sidetracked
here I almost forgot to talk about the
[ __ ] Lakers what the hell was that
what in God's name was that [ __ ]
debacle that's how you go out Los
Angeles Lakers you call yourself what
the [ __ ] was Magic talking about when
you were a classy organization since
when I think you showed your true colors
bunch of goddamn that's how you send out
Phil Jackson the [ __ ] red Arabic of
of this era that's how you send him out
by elbowing that little white guy from
the YMCA you see that little spaz coming
down the [ __ ] pain I don't know he was
like maybe an inch taller than I was he
just looks like some guy you know who
just you know let you know those guys
those short guys are the worst whenever
he played pickup hoop you know they got
their [ __ ] balls right on your leg
just playing ridiculous defense that was
that guy so it was part of it that I
actually thought was mildly funny that
he elbowed him he went beyond the
floating rib he cut that rib that's
right in your [ __ ] armpit but uh
seriously man what a [ __ ] horrific
way to go out you know what's funny this
is how much I hate the goddamn Lakers is
I didn't even watch I didn't even watch
a minute of basketball for months I
think the last time I watched a game was
when I went to a Memphis Grizzlies
Lakers game I don't watch hoop I think
it's [ __ ] boring as hell
Pro hoop everybody gets six
there's 11 guys on each team's that's a
hundred and thirty-two [ __ ] files and
then once they get in the penalty the
[ __ ] game is decided by unguarded
shots from the foul line is [ __ ]
horrific it's horrific but if I see the
Lakers about ready to fail that's when I
tune in and I got to tell you I was out
on Mother's Day do you guys have a good
Mother's Day by the way anybody out
there did anybody out there order pearl
flowers I haven't heard a [ __ ] word
from them so I'm taking that as a bad
sign
I don't know that I sold any bouquets
Omar last week I actually had for the
first time I had advertising here on
this podcast and I was all excited right
and I did sort of my own brand of
podcasting advertising right where you
sort of drop you know hints about serial
killers and incest and possibly you say
[ __ ] in the middle of the read right and
I don't think I don't know that I sold
any yeah I didn't work too well well you
know I I try I tried to go the [ __ ]
everyman room I try to be I'll just make
this [ __ ] conversational I'll just say
it the way I said I thought I'd paint it
a nice picture I was talking about love
what did you get your mother's mother
for Mother's Day uh just Chris Baldy a
deal like your mother she's okay she's
all right so yes you kind of gets on my
nerves you know yeah you know it's
definitely I kind of do it just because
I have to have a really good okay so you
just got our card yeah when did you get
it Mother's Day Sunday once you get
Friday you got a Friday right the
pickings were pretty slim weren't they
Oh totally yeah sure and that's what I
was saying by the time you get in there
the only thing that's left is like the
fart joke card yeah or the one that's
like mildly incestuous right over the
top of your mom yeah exactly that's what
I said that's what I said I'm already so
d [ __ ] flowers I haven't heard one
goddamn peep from the people over at
ProFlowers you want [ __ ] that [ __ ] them
and [ __ ] their [ __ ] flowers right you
call me with updates I'm too insecure I
can't deal with this silence you know
it's funny I bet I sold a bunch of them
and now I just told them to go [ __ ]
themselves
it's a Nevel you know what I'm doing I'm
just gonna do this park I want
advertising on this thing but I'm gonna
continue to do it the way I do it and
when when people finally you know
there'll be products that that fit into
saying [ __ ] in the middle of it right
absolutely alright so anyways the
[ __ ] Lakers the goddamn Lakers lose
and I had just it just thrilled me to
know when but I got to tell you
something they went out like a bunch of
[ __ ] all right a bunch of 7-foot
[ __ ] that I would never say it to
their [ __ ] faces but I'm saying it
right now in the safety of this
soundproof room
what the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] told that guy
to take his goddamn shirt off and he
wasn't even in shape Andrew Bynum maybe
you didn't blow out your ankle every
time you crossed your [ __ ] legs you
could do what goddamn sit-up how dare
you how dare you do something like that
with a man who's got 11 championships I
don't know what [ __ ] kills me is I'm
actually psyched hopefully that Phil
Jackson's gonna retire because he has
the ability to to to coach a team with a
bunch of stars much like a Joe Torre and
I'm really hoping that [ __ ] is
gonna quit you know and go [ __ ] stare
at his navel and do all that Zen [ __ ] as
he takes ecstasy or whatever the [ __ ] it
is he does just get out of it just get
out of the league I didn't give a [ __ ]
if you get back in the league dojo in
the heat I don't give a [ __ ] just get
away from the Lakers right but this is
what killing me I'm hearing rumors that
the Lakers are gonna get Dwight Howard
you know cuz he wants to come out here
and be a [ __ ] movie star and I was
just joking about that on Kevin and
being like one of these basketball
players gonna realize that they don't
have a shot at being a [ __ ] movie
star cuz they're too goddamn tall you
know don't you see how ridiculous you
look in street clothes have you ever
seen a professional basketball player
off the court like standing in a bar
they're [ __ ] they got a duck every
three seconds so they don't get hit by a
ceiling fan they're freaks they're
absolute [ __ ] freaks you think you're
gonna sit there and be like a love
interest maybe if they remake Conan the
Barbarian and you want to sit on the
back of a [ __ ] Clydesdale and your
feet are still dragging on the ground we
could stick in that it's just pissing me
off the Dwight Howard's gonna he's gonna
come out here and Kobe might get another
[ __ ] rink he that guy has no moves
right do you realize the amount of
people who could kick the living [ __ ]
out of me that I've already trashed why
don't I trash somebody who can't do
anything how about a sama bin Laden
everybody huh there's one [ __ ]
won't be knocking on any cave doors
anymore
you don't blows on my mind as I am
totally into conspiracy theory but the
conspiracy theory that people have that
he was that he was already dead or even
better that he's still [ __ ] alive it
actually made me laugh you know paranoid
fellow paranoid psychos out there if a
sama bin Laden was still alive right and
you hanging out with them in America is
sitting here gloating having one of
their first truly proud days I feel
since September 11th because that shit's
just been hanging over this country
wouldn't you just make a video with the
sama holding the [ __ ] Pakistani
Gazette for that day maybe you guys go
over to the water park are you allowed
to do that in that part of the world do
they add there Six Flags infiltrated
there yet the [ __ ] infidels have
we've we've been given you a theme park
you know did we come up with some sort
of Arab [ __ ] Mickey Mouse that we
could sell to you maybe stick a [ __ ]
Starbucks right next to it you know
wouldn't you just do that make the video
and be like I'm still alive go [ __ ]
yourself America and then Obama would
look like an [ __ ] and then he would
be [ __ ] for 2012 for saying that that
Osama was dead or if he died years
before why wouldn't you just released
that video I don't get it you know like
even even I'm not that [ __ ] paranoid
and I think it's a great thing and all
you [ __ ] losers out there who were
trying to be all [ __ ] deep going like
me and what's everybody cheering about
about the killing of a father of a
fellow human being because he [ __ ]
killed 3,000 people you [ __ ] you know
I love these [ __ ] idiots who were
trying to be like all [ __ ] deep as I
sitting there going like oh you know we
got mad at them when they cheered when
the [ __ ] towers went down and now
here we are cheering when Osama gets
killed it's like well here's the
difference all right
those Osama bin Laden actually is a
[ __ ] mass murderer who created 9/11
all right so that's what we killed we
didn't just [ __ ] kill a whole bunch
of [ __ ] innocent people and started
Aaron isn't that the difference ah go
[ __ ] yourself okay you got a rabid dog
in your neighborhood you [ __ ] put it
down okay do you think that and I don't
like how this guy's being made out by
some people Sam Biddle I'm like he's
some sort of a [ __ ] rebel he wasn't
he was a goddamn psychopath
and if he was running the world would
you want I don't I don't think I'd want
to be a chick right I wouldn't want to
be not only not part of his religion but
practicing the religion the way he'd
feels in a different way than he feels
you should that guy was a [ __ ] maniac
all right I thought he was a rebel he
should be living in a cage not sitting
in a [ __ ] mansion guys got a bigger
house than I do
[ __ ] him he was a rich kid he was
rebelling against his dad you got two
beans to the cabbage and they throw him
in a lake I love it you know it's funny
I got it oh [ __ ] Saved by the Bell
Saved by the Bell I think this might be
Jim Norton you got a pickup he's picking
up the phone he's picking up the phone
it's your wife you know what no no it's
all right
yeah why the [ __ ] didn't you know what
you know what a loser I am I didn't even
realize at that moment wasn't
professional Jesus Christ I was all
excited she was supposed to be on like
like 15 minutes ago I got a feeling it
ain't gonna happen
busy man like him busy man like him yeah
I do but I'm not gonna bug him he knows
he's supposed to call in but I mean I
don't know if he's wrapping up I don't
know what [ __ ] time it is over there
you know it's gonna be [ __ ] you know
what might be the comedy of this [ __ ]
episode is that I came down to this
studio and then nobody calls him
no absolutely nobody calls in Jesus
Christ what do I do here do I hit pause
on the recording and then call my
publicist is this what I have to do any
port in a storm huh what do you think
all right [ __ ] hit pause for half a
second sorry every but this is then you
know what this isn't even gonna be a
pause in your guy's world this is just
gonna [ __ ] flow alright hit pause
alright we're back is that that thing's
not moving over there the old EKG
monitor are we back
yeah oh I see all right well we're back
and I don't know what the [ __ ] happened
all I know was Dave Attell is supposed
to be our next guest oh [ __ ] me do you
guys realize the level of high hopes
that I had for this [ __ ] podcast I
was actually in a real studio I actually
got a real professional here to work the
goddamn board the levels were gonna be
great I was gonna have people calling in
last week I had advertising I mean it
was all good what could go wrong
you know what it's like anybody see that
mark that 34:30 Marcus Dupree story I
couldn't even get through it this guy's
like one of the greatest running backs
that never made the pros he actually
finally got to the pros he played a few
games with the Rams of some [ __ ] but I
wanted to feel bad for the guy but he
was such a dope and he was surrounded by
a bunch of dopes that I couldn't feel
bad for him I just had to shut it off it
was just and then I got another
opportunity I was good shape so cool
aboveboard
ohm and it's just like Eric go [ __ ]
yourself you know I'm weird man I am
like a total [ __ ] like liberal and I
and I I I adjusted my liberal thought
well you know I will definitely listen
to somebody else's side of the argument
but if you're not [ __ ] working to dig
yourself out of a [ __ ] hole then you
know bury yourself I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm not gonna still sit there who's that
chick with the big head from all in the
family she's always standing next to
people who need a sandwich right I don't
give a [ __ ] at that point you know that
didn't even make sense you know what
it's really trying to say it's like yeah
it's like I had a buddy of mine just
[ __ ] his whole his whole life became
about weed and he just was smoking it
all the [ __ ] time he was getting high
at work getting [ __ ] flunking drug
test then he starts calling me up hey
man can you give me some money man it's
like no go [ __ ] yourself so you can do
what go buy a bag and pay your rent you
[ __ ]
you know I if you're in a hole and
you're reaching up out of it go and help
me out I'll reach down and pull you up
but when you're facedown digging a
deeper asking me to throw money into it
go [ __ ] yourself have I said go [ __ ]
yourself enough in the last couple of
minutes
um all right you know I'm just gonna
plow ahead with this podcast and just do
it how I normally do it I'm just gonna
[ __ ] riff for the rest of the hour
and you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
let go of hoping that somebody calls in
one of the stars of this tour that is
going to be at the DAR Constitution Hall
in Washington DC Stars Jim Norton Jim
Breuer Dave Attell and myself and I am
beyond [ __ ] excited to play this gig
May 13th this this weekend Friday 13th
that's what I'm supposed to be hyping
here if I could actually just somehow
stop my brain from jumping from subject
to subject that's that's the mission of
this [ __ ] podcast is to hype that
date but uh that actually that venue
that's where Eddie Murphy take delirious
that's where Chris Rock taped one of his
specials I don't think it was bring the
pain but it's still Chris Rock and
Martin Lawrence taped their so as a
stand-up comedy fan slash geek slash
comedian I am beyond excited to be there
and I'm hoping that someone's gonna call
in from the tour on this show I don't
know if it's gonna happen though you
know it's like it's after the all-star
break we just lost seven games in a row
and that last playoff spot is really
getting distant I'm starting to let go
I'm [ __ ] letting go of it [ __ ] it no
one's calling it at least it'll sound
good right people it'll sound nice you
know anyways you know I was talking
about earlier and this is what's really
fascinating to get myself back into
shape I've dropped like ten pounds I'm
trying to hold it off [ __ ] actually
salads can you believe that [ __ ] who are
you a [ __ ] queer yes I'm eating salad
some salad eat and [ __ ] and you got to do
it this is the thing this is what I've
learned and I might have stated this
before but this is the [ __ ] thing
about being a guy women always [ __ ]
about how when they put weight on they
put it on their ass and their thighs
okay which as bad as that must be you
know feeling like you're dragging a
tugboat down the [ __ ] Street you know
your kids are sitting there with cereal
in their hair that's gotta suck but at
least with the female form you know
gives you guys something to [ __ ] hold
on to something to slap
you know when he's banging you from
behind acting like you're somebody else
pushing your face into the pillow you
know with guys we put our [ __ ] weight
on it all goes through our goddamn head
I don't I don't know what it is and it
is crucial as a man in your 30s and 40s
you got to do cardio man or else you're
gonna get that big [ __ ] Ted Kennedy
head and I was starting to get it
and there's a few people out there that
have just that that are really you know
like when they do those those for those
of you live in the Midwest or possibly
Tampa you know when they do those
before-and-after photos of what it's
like when you're on meth you know and
the one on the left you always look like
some angelic kid who's like student
class president and then the next one
you look like you're in a [ __ ] zombie
movie they ought to do that about guys
with it with like gain and [ __ ]
weight and the first billboard that they
should use and I hate to out somebody I
hate naming names in the podcast but
[ __ ] Yngwie Malmsteen how do you say
his goddamn name I am a child of the 80s
and this guy was like you know the 80s
was all about how [ __ ] fast you could
play the goddamn guitar and this guy
actually blew past Steve Vai that's how
[ __ ] fast he played and you know I
don't know what happened to the guy his
[ __ ] head is this there's a monitor I
wish you guys could see the [ __ ] mic
that's not remembered maybe the old TV
ad when you got a 27-inch screen TV
before flat screens came out remember
that [ __ ] and you thought you were the
[ __ ] you could actually host a Super
Bowl party cuz you got that thing that's
what his head looks like looks like one
of the old-style [ __ ] TVs just
sitting on there and this is the thing
he still teases his hair up to the
[ __ ] moon he wears leather pants he's
an absolute [ __ ] he's a mess so there's
two things I think you got it you got to
do as a guy is one you got to do the
card you got to lay off the booze I
think I'm actually gonna come full
circle and start advocating smoking weed
as long as you don't get the munchies
get the purse get that prescription if
he can do it you get that we smoked that
weed that doesn't give you the munchies
then he can get buzzed a little bit but
then you don't chow and then I don't
know maybe
you cannot [ __ ] end up like these
guys you don't to be that guy going back
to your high school reunion just
bursting out of your button-down shirt
you know that big [ __ ] I own a yacht
head you know it's just bumping into
[ __ ] head getting hit by ceiling fans I
just don't want to [ __ ] be that guy
but uh we're gonna have pictures up on
the the mm podcast.com is that thing
blinking no I thought I saw it blinking
I was really praying Jesus I didn't even
prepare for this podcast we know what I
realize I actually have like people
asking me for advice let's uh let's
let's read a couple of things everybody
considering this whole thing is just
going down the absolute [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we
got a caller oh hello Dave Attell hey G
well I'm psyched you actually called Jim
Norton never uh never called it I felt
like I was hosting like a telethon on on
basic cable going keep keep those keep
those calls coming in and there was like
three operators behind me just clearly
not on the phone what's that Jesus yeah
is there any way can you call us back oh
wait wait I can hear you now I can hear
you now Dave all right Dave you are
calling in because we are playing the
dark Constitution Hall may 13th this
Friday the 13th the antisocial tor
starring Jim Breuer Dave Attell Jim
Norton and myself and I want to thank
you for calling in the show you're the
only member of the of the tour that
actually took time out to call in yeah
but I'm calling because I love this show
and I think it's gonna be a great run at
the at the in DC yeah I gotta win I got
yeah I can hear you I hope you can hear
me dude I swear to God I met k-rock
Studios I'm not doing this for my
[ __ ] bedroom this is the heart this
is the whole purpose the whole purpose
Dave of me getting out of my apartment
and doing this [ __ ] this way so it would
actually sound professional so when I
had one of the [ __ ] best comics out
there call in I could actually
hyrum it's been a [ __ ] Dave it's
been an absolute [ __ ] anyway I called it
last night at 2:20 in the morning and
they had no idea who I was
wire that was my that was my fault I
should have said 220 in the afternoon
I'll just talk it doesn't matter oh god
we losing them yeah you know what Dave
yeah
[ __ ] dad Jesus Christ what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know I could have done
this [ __ ] I could have done this [ __ ]
from my [ __ ] house I could already
had this done I've heard it I could have
already uploaded this [ __ ] and I could
be going to the airport right now
I don't know if I told you this Omar I'm
actually I'm doing another episode of
Glee this is my second episode yeah it
hasn't come out yet
okay but I'm doing another one and we
actually got to go to New Mexico we're
doing like this this send up a pee-wee
Herman's Mexican Hat dance oh wow so I
got a fly out to New Mexico to go do
this [ __ ] and they wanted me to fly out
earlier there we go
this is gonna be Dave again I'm is that
him no Jesus can you believe this can
you guys believe the level of
unprofessionalism that's [ __ ] going
on right now we're not editing out any
of this [ __ ] this is [ __ ] horrific
who was that Dave so he's gonna be
calling back you know something I always
thought it was odd that I do these by
myself and now I don't now I am totally
[ __ ] sold he's back Dave what's going
on then this is great let's you know
[ __ ] all this let's let's just get into
everybody knows we're going to be at a
Constitution Hall this Friday the 13th
the anti social network tour Jim Norton
Jim Breuer Dave Attell and myself for
comics for the price of one in the
middle of a recession I don't know why
the [ __ ] you wouldn't buy this ticket
but having said all that Dave if I could
just
get it off of this [ __ ] subject I saw
a bunch of [ __ ] this morning where
people are coming back around saying
that America shouldn't be cheering you
know with Samas death because it's a
death of a fellow [ __ ] human being on
some level and I'm about as liberal as
they come and I got what do you think
about that
she'll be cheering yeah like people are
going you know somebody died doesn't it
seem weird to be cheering about the
death of somebody well I like I first of
all I think we should be cheering and
the fact that uh we got those kids off
of Facebook and out on the streets doing
backflips and you know a beach ball
around instead of a human head which is
how they would have done it in the
Middle East there you go it had a nice
little game of head soccer and no I
think we earned it
we which we call it uh you know living
in New York City it's nice to see
cheering that doesn't involve some kind
of parade you know like whether it be of
the Latino variety or the Halloween Day
parade which is Oh exactly yeah one from
women for everyone
but the fun thing about it bill is that
like as we're getting more information
about him he's becoming less like like
evil and just more normal and sad like
the rest of us like he lives in two
rooms with three women and he spent most
of his time on the computer you know
it's just like looking at TV sighing his
beard I got a minute I was a little
jealous that he had probably a bigger
apartment tonight he guy was living in a
[ __ ] mansion I have to tell you Dave
I got it I got it I do have to give the
guy props as far as how long it took us
to find us because I got to ask you this
if if an entire nation was looking for
you like how long do you think it would
take him to catch it yeah yeah ten
minutes this guy for his little
infrastructure jumping from cave to cave
I mean I you know ten years that's
almost as amazing as how long Magic has
lived with HIV but I think Pakistan did
let us down but they are our best friend
and you know much like any friends you
give him a lot of money and they
tell you what you want to hear and
meanwhile they're [ __ ] you over so I
I really can't see why everyone's so
surprised about it but I think we should
slam them a bit here's my idea ready
yeah they have to come in last at the
parade of the Olympics okay
wait for all the other countries Peru
Paraguay Pakistan I'm sorry
no you have to wait there after in
Zimbabwe a year yeah it's no more
alphabetical it's by order of country
who is helping us on war on terror and
they can come in and Germany will be
like we went through this you know
they'll get over it eventually you know
you know your world trance music and you
know bicurious porn but uh that's just
how it is
so yeah I'm a little I'm a little upset
with Pakistan but I think it was a great
win and I like how they had to describe
to people with the Navy SEALs or I guess
any any who they describe that too
because every guy in their life wanted
to be a Navy SEAL at one point like nope
I'm gonna be a Navy SEAL oh wait that
involves a lot of swimming outside of a
pool yeah you gotta have abs right there
I was out I for some reason thought that
when I was a kid I didn't realize that
they did [ __ ] on land I thought they
were like the real live Aquaman
like if there was oh if there was a bad
ship they come over the side with a
knife in their mouth well it's land sea
and hair though so you know if he had
like let's say put on like a jet pack
they would have followed him into the
clouds I like to how [ __ ] people are
trying to like are we gonna see the
identity of the people that whack down I
mean just like why would you think they
know did we ever see the identity of
those other two guys in the shrubs who
shot Kennedy they always give me the one
guy they'll give me like I know I will
eventually meet these guys because I
play a lot of the funny bones and improv
sounds near where they live and any Jew
who was in the military will be coming
out to me like you know I was a dude who
shot a man that was me you know trying
to keep it on the down-low can I have
can I have a free DVD there mr. Attell
speaking of which do you have anything
anything you want to hype as far as
uh-oh I know wait a minute you know what
I Dave Attell actually is it okay to one
now
your upcoming TV show no but yeah I'm
working on a project um bill you were
very cool and you have to take a look a
little bit at it involves it's it's a
little dirtier but I think it's going to
be fun and that should come around
sometime the summer I did a show with
Bill where we look at watch porn so you
know believe it or not it's it's not
only is it hilarious but the way they
did it because I was worried some of the
stuff that we were watching I was I was
wondering how you guys were gonna pull
that off and get that on air and I'm not
gonna give away what they did but I
watched it and I on the last date we did
up in Foxwoods and I thought it was it
was hilarious it was actually genius
with what you guys were doing because
some of that stuff was pretty hardcore
and it was actually hilarious to watch
and I don't know I I think I don't know
I don't want to jinx it but I think he
got a good shot with that one not going
away
you know it's very hard I know you got
like you do a lot of road are you doing
this tour with me and Norton and Brewer
and also you got those podcasts and
going and I think it's kind of cool that
you're in the studio you know and you
know is this kind of like a dream I
guess it's kind of like bumped up to
like regular you know like this is like
the real deal I mean like are you
dressed like a radio guy oh absolutely I
have I have a rock t-shirt on from the
70s I'm gonna have the wacky guy who
makes sound effects in that type of [ __ ]
I'm eating a breakfast burrito no matter
what time it is Dave I've got to put you
on hold we got the weather guy coming up
next I'm joking I'm joking totally
joking he was so good at it I was like
oh I'm so used to that lecture whatever
that's because I went into my my radio
guy voice that's not good radio name how
about like I said you know how about
like BB or a bang bang or yeah it has to
either be an abbreviation or there has
to be some of this might my sidekick has
to have like an an animal name you know
yeah you listen to BB in the Gazelle
here live on 97.1 we got this nuts guy
coming in and then I'll ask you the
worst [ __ ] questions that you've
heard of zillion times Dave do you get
nervous before you go out on stage
yeah you know what I love I like when
people uh radio guys always ask me about
like going on stage when like I've had
radio guys open for me and they look
like terrified like they've never seen
the audience that they talk to every
morning yeah that's what they look like
yeah they're always drinking all -
they're always drinking before they go
out on stage - just trying to calm the
nerves it's hilarious you know like you
know I gotta get out of here man I gotta
what t-shirts concert down and then you
know I'm opening a car dealership
tomorrow so now they would sounds like a
busier life than me I'm jealous
well what I think it's gonna be a good
show and so those are the people who
come to Foxwood and of course when we
were in in Atlantic City this is our
first show outside of the casino world
now I am against it but the rest of the
guys think that we have to juice make to
make it happen so I'm going with these
guys but I saw there's like a casino act
exclusively like a Sonny and Cher you
remember like I like I like the
husband's you know like wheat or
exclusively Burma casinos you know
absolutely you know and like conventions
and stuff like that and then you know
there's uh you know you guys still have
like a chance but I'm kind of an old
hack writing an old credit so I feel
like this is perfect for me you know
like eventually I'll like work at the
casino you know it'll be a greeter at
the casino you know before you hit the
cruise ship you know I always felt
casinos when you when you sign that debt
you know I will stay here all year round
out in Vegas that's yeah that was
basically landlocked cruise ship gig was
basically at you you were you had a fear
of the ocean but you've definitely
tapped but you've definitely tapped out
from the business but I have to admit
though every once in a while like when
I'm sick of doing the road you start
thinking you start lying to yourself
basically that you know what I think I
could do that you know I'll just get
myself a nice house and I'll just do the
just do the Flamingo every [ __ ]
weekend but uh I don't think I could
handle what's that yeah you know like
one day it's fifty I go to Vegas like
buy a house with enough room in the back
so it could be like a shooting range and
or being my stripper wife you know well
like will run that during the day at
night I'll be my my she s Joe and then
you know we'll just slowly die of lung
cancer and that's what it is
what do you know I've talked to a lot of
people like the the security people out
there in Vegas as far as like some of
the bigger entertainers I'm always
fascinated with that stuff
and I think that they are fully aware of
how batshit crazy you go having as a
performer having to work not only a
casino but the same [ __ ] casino you
know five six nights out of the week and
I'm fascinated with how little time all
the performers like spend out there like
someone's trying to tell me like all of
them I heard like like George Carlin
when he would do like the two weeks they
would have like a limo waiting right
like they would pull up like five
minutes or ten minutes before the show
he would get out he do his hour say
thanks a lot good night before the crowd
even put like that jackets on to go back
out to the casino floor he's already in
the car heading back to wherever the
hell he's staying and the best one I
heard was Celine Dion evidently gets
helicoptered from her [ __ ] house to
the top to the top of the casino does a
show punchers herself in the chest a
couple of times to get the notes out and
then she goes right back up and flies
back to her [ __ ] house totally they
fly in and they extract her well maybe
they'll shoot her in the leg
exactly well that girl's available now
so where are the Housewives of a
ba-ba-ba City you know what I've
actually heard that they have even worse
plastic surgery than the American ones
that's why they weigh that little veil
that's that's that's the rumor on the
Internet
all right well before we before I get
out of here Dave I just I really
appreciate you coming here and eating up
some minutes yeah yeah yeah I know
you're a you're a busy guy and
everything and I got to tell you guys I
can't oh I like usually when you hype
something you're over hyping it you're
saying it's better than it is but I got
to tell you I I've done I've done four
shows with these guys in every show I'm
standing to this side of the stage
watching everybody this is this is
you're out of your [ __ ] mind if you
don't come out to this thing okay I'm
not talking about myself these other
three guys who are on this tour are
absolutely killing it every night and
we're going to be at the dark
Constitution Hall this Friday May 13th
please come down tickets tickets are
going fast and how about it for the
wonderful Dave Attell for calling in the
show thank you very much man you were my
first callin I brother see you Friday
all right see you all right there we go
now if this was a professional show and
had some sort of advertising then we're
gonna be black in five minutes and I go
down the hall right drink a coffee take
a [ __ ] or whatever it is Eve morning
people do how far into this thing hours
[ __ ] we're coming up on an hour Jesus
all right you know what what you know
what I'm just gonna get into the normal
[ __ ] that I do for this week oh my
god I'm gonna read some stuff Omar do
you remember back when you were in
elementary school and they made you read
out loud and there was always that kid
who was so [ __ ] horrific you thought
he was like borderline [ __ ] yeah
that's who I am so if you thought we
were gonna get out of here on time it
ain't happening so [ __ ] put your feet
up on the console there cuz I'm about
ready to start reading out loud all
right here we go this is gonna be the
the advice for for this week for some
stupid reason you guys keep asking me
for advice hi Bill just leave me some
background I'm a 36 year old Asian woman
that was born and raised in the Bay Area
mmm I've been married for six years and
I have a beautiful baby girl they always
start off nice yeah everything's great
there's a nice summer breeze blowing up
my skirt um the only reason I am telling
you this is because I wanted you to know
that there are wives mothers and Asian's
that listen to your podcast to think you
are funny do I think you're an [ __ ]
yes but you're a funny [ __ ] and
that's all that matters this just check
is cool as hell don't ever let a few
idiots that can't take a joke joke get
you down all right so a few podcasts ago
you commented that not not every not
very many women we're writing in I
decided that I should start Jesus Christ
this is this is exactly how they tell a
[ __ ] story three minutes before when
do we get to the meat of this [ __ ]
couple of weeks ago you sounded down and
I was watching Oprah and I realized I
haven't called my friend from high
school
so anyways I decided I should start
pulling my weight shoot you an email for
advice I know I know that you grew up in
a family of all boys um can you please
tell me what is the best way to deal
with a troubled male teenager one of my
friends is a single mom and is worried
about her 14 year old son Jesus this is
gonna be rough he used to be a pretty
happy kid but lately he's become very
quiet and keeps himself most of the time
my friend doesn't know if anything is
really wrong but when she asks is for
for his response his response as always
everything's fine mom everything's fine
all right close the door thank you he's
not rude and he's not getting into any
trouble that she knows of she's just
concerned because he comes home from
school and goes straight to his room she
wants to know if everything is okay but
is unsure of how to approach the
situation as you know men don't always
love opening up let alone a teenage boy
do you have any suggestions yes I do as
a matter of fact first thing I would be
worried about is I don't know it was
easy lovesick he or is he is he being
bullied at school
maybe that's what it is did something
[ __ ] horrific something unbelievably
humiliating the happen to him and now
there's a [ __ ] youtube video out
there of it with 1.2 [ __ ] million
hits that's one of the worst things
about something awful happening to you
now as a kid is these [ __ ] [ __ ]
other kids they all have cameras they
film it and you [ __ ] your [ __ ] life
is over so I don't know what it is I
mean I hope it's not drugs or anything
like that but if I was in that situation
and the kid wasn't opening up I try to
spend more time with them
you know what I'll compare this to I was
never able to pick up a girl in like a
meat market like in a bar I was never
able to do that [ __ ] because they had
the defenses up they're [ __ ] ready
for you to come at them that way and I
think when they're sitting in their
[ __ ] room they're just in that mode
you come in Saunders everything okay you
know plus I gotta hide their weed or
whatever's going on there but I think if
you just get them outside of that [ __ ] I
you know what I don't know I'm not a
[ __ ] parrot but I think at some point
I would just address say
I'm not trying to pry I'm not trying to
be an [ __ ] here but I've just noticed
that you seem a little quieter than
usual did you knock somebody up you know
eventually come around to that question
you know what that question I think I
think it's beyond me I guess that that's
what I would do I would try to I don't
know I don't know what the kids into
he's into if he's what are you in the
Bay Area
he likes the A's or the [ __ ] Giants
buy tickets and then lie and say oh I
won these tickets at work so then he
won't feel like a douche going with his
mom take it to the game with the mom you
shoot the [ __ ] you have a good time and
eventually I don't know he get a couple
of beers in him no he's 14 I don't
[ __ ] know IIIi think I would just
address the fact that he seems quieter
than usual I would see if he's hanging
out with anybody new or different and if
they if they look like John bender from
the [ __ ] Breakfast Club I'd be
worried that maybe he was dabbling in
drugs I don't know but that's a weird
age I know that's right when I started
feeling like a [ __ ] freak like my
elementary school days were good and
right around junior high that's that
that went good high school high school
where's where kind of went off the rails
for me so he's right about 14 I don't
know maybe he's a freshman and he feels
like you know all these [ __ ] you know
seniors are freaking him out I don't
know he just feels like he's got to
start all over again I have no [ __ ]
idea that's beyond me and I'm gonna give
you a bad advice and then I'm gonna get
sued so sorry but thank you for writing
in I do appreciate it all right
Jesus this this might be the worst
[ __ ] podcast I've ever done you know
with my luck the people at Carrick are
actually listening to this and they were
actually considering giving me a [ __ ]
job and now it's over right well I don't
need you all right bill hey one of my
best friends has been going to church
for years Oh geesh and previously it has
never bothered me at all I grew up
Catholic and like so many Catholics I no
longer attend church gee why was that
was it the kid [ __ ] or the money they
took from the Nazis in World War two
anyways but it doesn't bother me in the
least if someone wants to go that's how
I feel honestly a few months ago my
friends started asking me if I
like to go to church with them Oh God I
politely declined that just gave me
douche chills that his [ __ ] arms
accidentally graze up against your hand
when he said it anyways since then my
friend has told me he feels it's his
mission to spread the word of God and
continues to ask me to go and as time
passes he's getting more aggressive with
his church sales pitch what started off
with him just slipping it into casual
conversation has now left
how the [ __ ] do you do that you want to
go to Subway yeah give me the Italian on
Italian bread and you know Jesus
evidently we used to be around Italy
wasn't he in Italy when he got crucified
so anyways he casually been slipping us
into the conversation now has led to me
receiving text messages that say the
following this this means more to me
than you know God has poured out love to
me and he is reaching out to you oh so
ignore if you must but there is a lot at
stake here to this I replied honestly if
it's my choice I don't want to go please
stop asking me about it I don't know how
many more ways I can request that his
was he responded with I'll hold off but
know this God loves you and will not
quit if I do oh my god it sounds like
the first draft of single white female
here comes my question bill what does
this why does this [ __ ] piss me off
so much because it's creepy why do these
why do these cults what do these cults
do to these people he is involved with
the church that people do joke around
about and do call a cult what would you
do if you or me at this point I don't
even want to talk to this guy because
these conversations are infuriating me
um there's nothing you can do you got to
look out for yourself you got to cut
this guy out of your life that's it it's
[ __ ] over he joined a goddamn cult
there's nothing you can do about it if
you try to get him to see the light and
not come out and come out of the cult
you're immediately going to be whatever
whatever creepy word they use in his
cult for the outsiders you know you're
you're one of the others and you're just
gonna drive them further into the [ __ ]
and cult all right hopefully he's good
with weaponry and you know if when the
FBI surrounds the compound and asked
them to come out nicely
let me guess is the guy at the top
does he have long you know that they're
following who started this cult does he
have long hair and a beard you know if
it's a white guy I think that that's how
it usually goes is he wearing high-top
gym sneakers are they waiting for some
sort of flying [ __ ] saucer dude you
know what I would do if I was you I I
would and this might actually help him
to come around just cut him out of your
life just stop answering his text
messages don't hang out with them
anymore and when he asks why say do cuz
you're out of your [ __ ] mind that's
why you're out are you [ __ ] mind
there's like 9000 religions on this
planet and they all say go somewhere
different why do you think you don't
even say why do you think you're right
you're out of your [ __ ] mind
all right you die you go in the ground
you become a fossil fuel with the
stegasaurus
that's it all right and someday if you
have any gift with any [ __ ] luck
you'll get extracted out of the ground
and you be going right through a [ __ ]
carburetor you know helping some [ __ ]
get to work maybe go over to his girl
house you know so he can get his first
piece of [ __ ] other than that it's all
[ __ ] horseshit all you need is the 10
commandments if you follow those if
there is some sort of after-party some
sort of VIP room at the end of your life
you're gonna [ __ ] get in all right
[ __ ] these people cut him out of your
life all right I think I got time for
one more then I gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here cuz like I said I gotta fly in
New Mexico and I'm doing another episode
of Glee and I know you guys think I'm
[ __ ] around but I'm telling you this
is episode number two and I got it down
but that iPad app bap bap all right
number three bill first can't thank you
enough for all the laughs in your weekly
podcast I just realized I don't have
enough time to read this because there
was something I wanted to talk about I'm
gonna close it on this one here's a
YouTube video you guys have to watch
this week all you got to do is search
Chuck Berry John Lennon Memphis or you
can just go to the mmm podcast calm and
you see this video and I don't know how
to describe this basically what goes on
here speaking of women as much as people
talk about the Beatles and how great
their music is was whatever you want to
say I totally agree with them I think
that the greatest band of all
but I have to be honest with you John
Lennon and Paul McCartney redefined
pussy-whipped okay they you know member
like when Jordan came into the NBA and
he just took it 20 years into the
[ __ ] future this is what these guys
did with being [ __ ] what people thought
they knew what [ __ ] what was you have
to watch this [ __ ] video it's John
Lennon is singing with Chuck Berry Chuck
Berry is probably one of the main
reasons why John Lennon Lennon ever
picked up a guitar so now he's on TV he
gets to play with his idol they're
playing Chuck Berry's hit in Memphis
okay John Lennon's got Yoko in his
[ __ ] band
they're in the middle of singing this
song on television and they're killing
it it's going great
and out of Yoko's playing some stupid
[ __ ] drum and even though she has no
[ __ ] talent whatsoever he's putting
her in the [ __ ] band just she'll shut
the [ __ ] up and stop nagging him because
he's too much of a [ __ ] [ __ ] to tell
her that she has no talent
all right the only reason why you're
here Yoko's cuz you're sucking my dick
all right no you can't play the bongos
but anyway she's up there playing the
bongos right so John Lennon Chuck Berry
two of the Great's of all time
harmonizing singing this hit from the
1950s that's what this moment's about
and Yoko in the middle of a can't handle
that she's not getting any shine she
takes the [ __ ] microphone out of the
stands starts playing the bongo and as
this singing you know go go Johnny go
whatever she picks up the mic and I
swear to god goes some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] and you see Chuck Berry's eyes
[ __ ] open as wide as they are and
it's that it's that [ __ ] look dude
you ever have like a buddy of yours and
he's dating some [ __ ] psycho but he's
in love with her so you can't [ __ ]
say anything and you're just sitting
there waiting for the [ __ ] lightning
bolt to hit your friend in the head
where he finally realizes that he's
dating a psycho [ __ ] Chuck Berry had
that look on his face dude I'm not even
joke I'm not even exaggeration yeah
that's what the [ __ ] she did and Chuck
Berry's like what the [ __ ] and it's kind
of like John that's your woman get her
in line and John
and does not even [ __ ] he doesn't
even blink he just he just keeps playing
and then she does it again later on in
that song and then you look at all the
other musicians and they they just keep
playing the song like Yoko isn't even
[ __ ] there and I I don't know I I
can't I thought I was going to be able
to describe it to a level feet up to you
to understand it but you got to watch
this video
John Lennon and what's-his-face Paul
McCartney putting that monotone
photographer not only does he have our
playing keyboards he's got a singing
background I mean the two of them I
don't think they just did not have their
women in line and I actually get
infuriated when I watched this video the
fact that John didn't just stop playing
in that moment and what he should have
done was dressed or down right there yes
I find you want to have a [ __ ] moment
this is your moment if you have a [ __ ]
and do that again I will slap you so
[ __ ] hard in the head your eyes are
gonna look like mine do you understand
me you play that [ __ ] bongo and you
shut your face you look like that [ __ ]
who crawled out of the [ __ ] well and
ring you understand me I don't mean why
I'm [ __ ] you I'm gonna be [ __ ]
anybody you can't play the pong bongos
you can't sing shut your [ __ ] face
and then he just walks back up to the
mic and just counts the band back in
right is that what the [ __ ] he should
have done all right whatever this thing
has been a [ __ ] I want to think I
want to thank Dave Attell for actually
calling in I got one one out of the
other three guys to call and Brewer said
he couldn't call in Jim Norton he's just
phenomenally busy plus the guy also put
together this tour so on I can't get it
upset at him and I'm [ __ ] here you
got half the goddamn tour right you got
two out of four just like the Beatles
Paul McCartney and who else is left
Ringo Starr wait a minute the other two
are dead
no not on this tour they're both alive
and then we're gonna be at Constitution
Hall Friday the 13th all might as well
hype the other dates this tours coming
through Chicago we're gonna beat the
Chicago theater on June 15th the
Paramount Theatre in Seattle on July 1st
and then we're going to be at Vegas I
forget the name of the casino on July
3rd all - next week and next week I
believe will be my 200th podcast so I'll
be eating cake next week alright that's
the podcast for this week I hope it made
sense I know it was a little bit of a
- [ __ ] but that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll talk to you next week
[Music]
you